as an archaeologist I most often asked
what my favorite discovery is the answer
is easy my husband Greg we met in Egypt
on my first big it was my first lesson
in finding unexpected wonderful things
this began an incredible archaeological
partnership years later I proposed to
him in front of our favorite pair statue
of the prince and princess
raaah hotel and no prett in the Cairo
Museum dating to 4,600 years ago I
thought if I was going to ask Greg to
spend the rest of his life with me then
I should ask him in front of two people
who had pledged to be together for
eternity
these symbols endure because when we
look at them we're looking at mirrors
they are powerful reminders that our
common humanity has not changed the
thrill of archaeological discovery is as
powerful as love because ancient history
is the most seductive mistress
imaginable many archaeologists have
devoted their lives to unraveling the
mysteries of the past under hot sun in
arctic winds and in dense rainforests
many seek some discover all worship at
the temple of possibility that one
discovery might change history on my
first day in Egypt I worked at a site in
the northeast Egyptian Delta and site
called Mindy's dating to four thousand
two hundred years ago in a cemetery the
picture of me I'm just in my bliss on
the dig surrounded by emerald green rice
paddies I discovered an intact pot
flipping it over
I discovered a human thumbprint left by
whoever made the vessel for a moment
good silk I didn't know where I was it
was because at that moment I realized
when we dig we're digging for people
nothing never are we so present as when
we are in the midst of the great past I
can't tell you how many times I've stood
in front of the pyramids of giza and
they leave me speechless I feel like the
luckiest person in the world
they are monument to our human
brilliance and everything that is
possible many cannot process the
brilliance is human I think that aliens
built them but this is ridiculous all
you need to do is get up close and
personal and see the hidden hand of man
in the children marks left by the tools
that built them the Great Pyramid of
Giza was built one stone at a time with
2.3 million watts with incredible
bureaucratic efficiency it is not the
pyramids that stand the test of time it
is human ingenuity that is our shared
human brilliance history may be cyclical
but we are singular I love what I do
because I learned that we haven't
changed I get to read about
mother-in-law jokes from Mesopotamia
3,500 years ago I get to hear about
neighbors cursing each other from 4,600
years ago in Egypt and my absolute
favorite from 3,300 years ago and Luxor
and inscriptions that describes
schoolboys who cut class to go drinking
kids these days I get to see the most
incredible architecture see stunning
sculptures I mean this is basically a
selfie in stone and see that we've
always rocked serious bling and also
we've been posting on walls and
obsessing about cats for thousands of
years archaeologists are the cultural
memory preservers and the spokespeople
for the billions of people and the
thousands of cultures that came before
us good science imagination and a leap
of faith of the trifecta we use to raise
the dead in the last year archaeologists
have made incredible discoveries
including new human ancestors from South
Africa tools from 3.3 million years ago
these are the oldest tools ever
discovered in Kenya and this from a
series of medical implements sound from
Blackbeard ships from 1718 what you're
looking at is a medical tool used to
treat syphilis ouch for each of these
there are thousands of other incredibly
important discoveries made by my
colleagues that do not make headlines
however I believe that the most
important thing we do as archaeologists
is acknowledge that past people existed
and live lives worth learning about can
you even imagine what the world would be
like today if we acknowledged all human
beings in this way so on a dig you have
a challenge
it often looks like this you can't see
anything where are we going to start
digging this is from a site south of
Cairo so let's have a look from space
again can't really see much what you're
looking at is a world view three
satellite image which has a point three
resolution that's ten inches this means
that you can zoom in from 400 miles in
space and see your tablet how do I know
about this it's because I'm a space
archaeologist
let me repeat that I am a space
archaeologist this means thank you
this means that I use satellite images
and process them using algorithms and
look at several differences in the light
spectrum that indicate varied things
under the ground that I get to go
excavate and survey by the way nASA has
a space archaeology program so it's a
real job so let's have a look again okay
again we're back at the site to south of
Cairo you can't see anything so keep
your eye on the red rectangle when we
process the image using algorithms think
like a space-based capstan this is what
you see this rectilinear form is an
ancient tomb that is previously unknown
and unexcavated and you all are the
first people to see it in thousands of
years
I believe we have barely scratched the
surface in terms of what's left to
discover in the Egyptian Delta alone
we've excavated less than 1/1000 of 1%
of the total volume of Egyptian sites
when you add to that the thousands of
other sites my team and I have
discovered what we thought we knew pales
in comparison to what we have left to
discover when you look at the incredible
work that my colleagues are doing all
around the world and what they're
finding I believe that there are
millions of undiscovered archaeological
sites left to find discovering them will
do nothing less than unlock the full
potential of our existence but we have
challenged over the last year we've seen
horrible headlines of incredible
destruction going on to archaeological
sites and massive looting by people like
ISIL ISIL has destroyed temples at
Palmyra who blows up a temple they
destroyed the tomb of Jonah and we've
seen looting at sites so rampant it
looks like craters of the moon knowing
isil's desire to destroy modern human
lives it's a natural extension for them
to destroy cultural identity as well
countless invading armies have done the
same throughout history
now we know that ISIL is profiting from
the looting of sites but we don't know
the scale this means that any object
purchased on the market today from the
Middle East could potentially be funding
terrorism when a site is looted it's as
if a puzzle already missing 90% of its
pieces that's had the rest obscured
beyond recognition this is ancient
identity theft writ large we know that
there are two kinds of looting going on
looting by criminal elements like ISIL
and then more local looting by those
that are desperate for money
we would all do the same to feed our
families I don't blame the local looters
I blame the middlemen the unethical
traffickers and an international art
market that exploits often ambiguous or
even completely non-existent laws now we
know looting is going on on a global
scale and it's increasing but presently
we don't have any tools to stop it this
is beginning to change my team and I
have just completed a study looking at
looting in Egypt and we looked at open
source data and maps the entirety of
looting across Egypt from 2002 to 2013
we found evidence of looting and site
destruction at 267 sites and mapped over
200,000 looting pits astonishing and
putting that data together you can see
the looting pits marked here and one
site as the looting got bad from 2009
2011 2012 hundreds and hundreds of pets
putting all the data together what we
found is that contrary to popular
opinion looting did not start to get
worse in Egypt in 2011 after the Arab
Spring but in 2009 after the global
recessions thus we've shown with big
data that looting is fundamentally an
economic issue if we do nothing to stop
the problem all of Egypt sites will be
affected by looting by 2040 but we are
at a tipping point we are the generation
with all the tools and all the
technologies to stop looting but we're
not working fast enough
sometimes an archaeological site can
surprise you with its resilience I am
just back from the field where I co-lead
a joint mission with Egypt's Ministry of
Antiquities at a site called Blish this
site dates to the Middle Kingdom of
Egypt between 2000 and 1750 BC the
Middle Kingdom was ancient Egypt
Renaissance period after a time of
intense internal strife and
environmental challenges each of
rebounded with an incredible resurgence
of art architecture and literature my
favorite period of time to study in
Egypt because it teaches us so much
about how we can survive and thrive
after great disasters now access sites
we had already mapped countless looting
pits leashes roll sites there would have
been thousands of people buried there
who lived and worked at the court of
Pharaoh and you can see this before and
after you see dozens of looting pits nor
fish this is in South flesh before and
after when we first visited the site we
could see the tombs of many high-ranking
officials that have been looted let me
put into perspective for you what was
taken
imagine a 2 meter by 2 meter area full
of coffins jewelry an incredible
statuary multiply that times over a
thousand that's what was taken so when
we started work my Egyptian co-director
Mohammed Yosef approached me and said we
must work at this one particular tomb it
that attacks by looters we don't do
anything they'll be back of course I
agreed but I didn't think we find
anything I thought the looters had
stolen everything what we started to
find was the most incredible relief I
mean look at this painting is just
stunning we started finding engraved
inscriptions and even the titles of the
tomb owner she had titles like overseer
of the army overseer of the Treasury I
began to have hope maybe just maybe we
would find his name for the ancient
Egyptians having their name last for
eternity was their goal and then one day
disappeared this is the name of the tomb
owner in tuff you can see it written out
here and hieroglyphs working together
with my Egyptian team we had restored
someone's name from 3900 years ago
we're together with my Egyptian
colleagues we celebrated this moment of
shared discovery what we were doing
together was right and true we found
this incredible fall store mostly intact
on it we read about in past and his
inscriptions
you can actually even see him seated
here what I realized is that everything
I had assumed about looted sites had
been proven wrong every day on site we
work together with 70 Egyptians as
colleagues and friends in the face of so
much hatred and ignorance against those
in the Middle East every moment on site
felt like a protest for peace when you
work with those that don't look like you
or think like you or speak like you your
shared mission of archaeological
discovery erases all superficial
differences what I learned this season
is that archaeology isn't about what you
find it's about what you can prove
possible so sometimes when you travel
you end up finding long-lost family not
those with whom you share genes but a
shared entually in the book of life this
is omar farooq my brother I'm Reza
goofty from a village just north of
Luxor coldest fifties are part of a
celebrated tradition in Egyptology to
help with digging and work for
organizations Omer is my CEO and CSL I
simply couldn't do work without him one
day many years ago when I was a young
graduate student and Omer was a young
goofty who couldn't speak much English
we learned completely randomly we were
born on the same year the same month and
the same day six hours apart twins
separated by an ocean but forever
connected for ancient Egypt is our
mother I knew that we'd always work
together not in my brain but in the part
of your soul that knows but not
everything can be explained
Yael mutter ya Habibi on the head back
alley I'll look to lucky Palmer my
brother I will always love you so just
before my first dig in Egypt
my mentor very famous Egyptologist
professor William Kelly Simpson called
me and Raghava he handed me a check for
$2,000 and said this is to cover your
expenses have a glorious adventure this
summer someday you will do this for
someone else
thus my TED Prize wishes partial pay
back plus interest for a great human
beings generosity and kindness so my
wish I wish for us to discover the
millions of unknown archaeological sites
around the world by creating a 21st
century army of global explorers will
find and protect the world's hidden
heritage which contains clues to
humankind's collective resilience and
creativity
so how are we going to do this we are
going to build with the Ted prize money
an online crowdsource
citizen science platform to allow anyone
in the world to engage with discovering
archaeological sites they're only a
couple hundred of us-based
archaeologists around the world it is my
dream to engage the world with helping
to find site and protect them what
you'll do is you'll sign in create a
username note this particular username
is already taken you'll take a tutorial
and you'll start work I want to notice
the outset that in no way will we be
sharing GPS data our mapping data for
sites we want to treat them like human
patient data and not reveal their
locations you'll then be dealt a card
from a deck whether it's twenty by
twenty meters or 30 by 30 meters and
you'll be looking then for futures my
team and I will attach processed
large amounts of satellite data using
algorithms in order for you to find
things so you'll be doing really good
science you'll then be starting to look
what do you see you see a a temple do
you see a tomb you see a pyramid do you
see any potential site damage or site
looting you'll then begin to mark what's
there and off to the side are always
going to be rich example of exactly what
you're seeing to help guide you all the
data that you help us collect will be
shared with vetted authorities and will
help create a new global alarm system to
help protect sites but it's not just
going to stop there
all the archaeologists with whom we
share your discoveries will take you
with them as they begin excavate them by
using periscope Google+ and social media
one hundred years ago
archaeology for the rich fifty years ago
it was for men now it's primarily for
academics our goal is to democratize the
process of archaeological discoveries
and allow anyone to participate 94 years
ago Howard Carter discovered the tomb of
King Tut
who is the next Howard Carter it might
be you by creating this platform we will
find the millions of places occupied by
the billions of people that came before
us if we want to answer the big
questions about who we are where we've
come from the answers to those questions
do not lie in pyramids or palaces but in
the cities and villages of those that
came before us if we want to learn about
the past it's time we inverted the
pyramids acknowledging that the past is
worth saving means so much more it means
that we're worth saving too and the
greatest story ever told is the story of
our shared human journey but the only
way that we're going to be able to write
it is if we do it together come with me
thank you
[Applause]
you